after 12 exhausting days the moment had
arrived to approve a deal to keep global
warming to one and a half degrees
yet moments before the gavel came down
objections came up
china and india wanting to soften
language on getting rid of coal
including
escalating effort to face down
unabated coal power
a last minute play met by many with
anger and disappointment that caught
president alok sharma couldn't hide as
he was forced to pass the deal
it's also vital that we
protect this package
it is so decided but a few moments later
the deal was done okay that's it that's
the moment
with visible
reluctance
alexander's just passed the glasgow
climate hack he's 1.5 still alive it's
weakened it's wounded it's just about
made it over the line the applause was
short and thin
most of the 200 countries here had
worked hard to keep a promise to phase
out coal in the text now changed to
phase down
we all know that european wealth
was built on coal
and if we don't get rid of coal
european death will also be built on
coal
we know full well
that coal has no future on behalf of the
marshall islands i wish to read into the
record
our profound
disappointment with the change in the
language on coal from phase out to phase
down
it could have been worse it was a day of
frantic diplomacy as the us and european
allies fought to defend weak offers on
finance and forests to keep developing
countries at the table
but crucially a line requiring all
nations to meet again next year with
better promises to cut emissions
survived and that's what keeps 1.5 just
about alive
this is a fragile win
and
we have kept
1.5 alive
that was our overarching objective when
we set
off on this journey two years ago taking
on the role of the cop presidency
designate
but i would still say that um
the pulse of 1.5
is weak at best the glasgow climate pact
puts the world on a very uncertain path
to 1.5 degrees
as for how history views it that all
depends on whether the 197 countries
here stick to their promises
tom clark sky news glasgow